chers amis chers françois notre dernier
conseil national a eu lieu le 2 juillet
ici même c'était souvenez-vous en
présence de celui qui aura présidé l'ump
de 2004 à 2016 notre pays de 2007 à 2012
et les républicains pendant deux ans je
veux à cette tribune est très
sincèrement comme vous l'avez fléchir
luc et cher daniel lui rendre hommage
devant le parlement de notre mouvement
vous l'avez compris il s'agit de nicolas
sarkozy
il a reçu dès notre famille il l'a
remise au travail
il s'est engagé pour et dans la primaire
de la droite et du centre
un exercice auquel nous n'étions pas
habitués mais dont nous nous sommes
plutôt pas mal sorti même la gauche a dû
reconnaître que ce fut un succès une
primaire qui fut avant tout un débat
d'idées entre sept personnalités de
talents qui ont leurs ambitions leurs
caractères mais savent aussi qu'ils
appartiennent à une même famille
ils sont capables de se rassembler quand
l'essentiel est en jeu
ils ont tenu promesse en soutenant tous
sans exception et dès le soir de son
élection
celui dont les sondages ne donnait pas
cher mais qui a pourtant réuni près de 3
millions de votants sur sa candidature
deux électeurs sur trois il est
désormais notre candidat
je veux bien sûr parler de françois
fillon
alors à toutes celles et tous ceux qui
ont été les artisans de ce bel exercice
démocratique c'est-à-dire vous tous ici
réunis ce matin et quelques sur nos
choix à la primaire j'adresse à cet
instant un immense merci nous sommes à
100 jours de la présidentielle du 23
avril et 7 mai la bei en outre-mer il ne
vous aura pas échappé que ce n'est pas
gagné et qu'il faut donc rester
concentré sur l'objectif
depuis que nous avons désigné notre
champion il fait en effet l'objet de
toutes les attaques et la créativité en
la matière est sans limite les coûts en
l'occurrence viennent de partout passons
sur les caricatures incessantes de dons
un adversaire politique
nous n'avons rien à en attendre mais
intéressons nous plutôt à ceux qui nous
interpelle ceux que nous côtoyons tous
les jours dans le cadre de nos
responsabilités d'élus nationaux locaux
ou de simples militants les républicains
ils peuvent manifester des inquiétudes
ou des incompréhensions sur telle ou
telle mesure du projet ils peuvent même
souhaité que le programme soit modifié
généralement quand ils ne ne se sont pas
encore totalement approprié
françois fillon l'a dit et répété son
projet pour la france est réfléchie et
cohérent il est le fruit de ses
convictions de ses rencontres avec les
français et de son expérience d'homme
d'état son projet peut être enrichie
approfondie mais pas dénaturer il ne
cède pas à la démagogie et emprunte
clairement le chemin de la vérité et du
courage
nous pouvons être persuadé que la
comparaison avec ses concurrents est
al'avantage de françois fillon
notre mission votre mission est
désormais d'en convaincre les français
forts de notre soif de reconquête après
5 ans de mandat désastreux de françois
hollande est conscient des attentes
fortes de notre pays
je crois que nous le pouvons et je ne
doute pas un seul instant que nous
trouverons
les mots pour le dire et rassembler les
français
nous avons un chef nous avons un projet
nous sommes le premier parti de france
nous avons la volonté le carré d'as est
entre nos mains et de surcroît nous ne
sommes pas seuls nous pouvons nous
appuyer dans chacune des fédérations sur
les 1500 comités locaux issus de la
société civile
ils ont joué un rôle majeur dans la
primaire et je pense particulièrement
aux jeunes et aux femmes sur lesquelles
nous fondons beaucoup d'espoir toutes et
tous nous aideront à faire connaître et
partager notre destin pour la france la
période des voeux bat son plein et
corneille inspiré ma conclusion nous
partîmes 500 mais par un prompt renfort
nous nous vîmes 3000 en arrivant au port
nous partîmes plus de 4 millions mais
parvint un gros effort nous nous vîmes
plus de 23 millions en arrivant au port
oui nous le pouvons
oui nous le ferons alors bonne année à
tous et surtout bonne santé
[Applaudissements]